the
realm do you know what the realm
is it's the Thousand Blades of aon's
enemies a story we agree to tell each
other over and over till we forget that
it's a
lie what's up ladies and gentlemen
welcome back for another Game of Thrones
in House of the Dragon update video in
this video I want to go over what house
of the Dragons actor Matt Smith said
during a recent interview Matt Smith who
is also known as Damon Targaryen on the
show recently revealed new information
about House of the Dragon second season
during his interview on the radio it
wasn't long before HBO gave their own
little official announcement in regards
to what Matt Smith said I'm actually not
sure what to think after reading this
because although House of the Dragons
actors should know this information what
he said does go against what HBO has
already officially announced a few
months ago now as you all know HBO has
been developing and creating house of
the Dragon second season for well over a
year most of you should have a good idea
about everything that has happened
during this off season if you've been
watching all of my videos not only are
they already done filming all the scenes
for the new season but they've already
released their first official teaser
video and in that video HBO revealed
when they will be releasing House of the
Dragon new season all we know for sure
is that it will be releasing this summer
at first we heard House of the Dragon
second season will release early this
summer which makes me think either June
or July however Matt Smith said
something different during his new
interview I will show you exactly what
he said then I'll show you what HBO said
after they found out he reveal the new
date now before I go any further I have
to let all of you know about this
amazing new offer I'd like to thank the
sponsor of today's video Factor as
someone with an extremely busy schedule
who exercises daily and likes to eat
healthy Factor has been a GameChanger
for me now that I've been eating it
every day Factor makes meeting your
nutritional goals easier than ever by
delivering dietitian approved meals meal
that are fresh and never Frozen right to
your doorstep each meal is created by
Factor's Gourmet chefs using fresh
ingredients to help you feel your best
all day long now this time of the year
is always really busy for us and we
don't always have the time to cook a
healthy meal at the end of the day with
Factor you can skip the trip to the
grocery store and save time on having to
chop up ingredients or meal prepping and
what I love most is there's little to no
clean up factors fresh never frozen
meals are ready in only two minutes so
all you have to do is heat enjoy then
get back to Smashing your daily goals
Factor really has something for everyone
with 34 plus weekly flavored packed
meals to choose from with only 550
calories or less one of my absolute
favorites is the fucili and ground pork
Ragu it has the best meaty and cheesy
spaghetti mixture and it also has some
delicious roasted green beans it's
incredibly filling and flavorful they
also have Gourmet plus options featuring
amazing ingredients like broccoli and
truffle butter I'm also really looking
forward to the new surf and turf steak
and shrimp that is coming soon you can
choose to try their Protein Plus meals
with 30 or more grams of protein in each
serving and they have 45 plus add-ons
including breakfast items like apple
cinnamon pancakes and bacon and cheddar
egg bites now if you're too busy this
fall to cook but you still want to make
sure you and your family are eating well
head to factor75.com or click the link
below and use the code talking thrs 50
to get 50% off your first Factor box
again that's factor75.com and use the
code talking Thrones to get 50% off your
first Factor box once again I have to
thank factor for sponsoring today's
video all right now let's have a look at
what Matt Smith said the article reads
House of the Dragon Star Matt Smith may
have accidentally revealed the show's
release window for the new season the
actor also known as Damon Targaryen on
the Game of Thrones series spilled the
beans during an interview on the Zoe
ball breakfast show ahead of the show's
confirmed return later this year when he
was asked by the radio host when fans
can expect to see the targaryens back on
the screen he said August I think this
summer yeah the former Doctor Who star
went on to reveal that despite finishing
filming last year the next installment
isn't ready yet I've not seen any of it
yet but we finished it last year so
we've got to do all the ADR and all that
business he said now as I'm sure most of
you already know this new season of
House of the Dragon will only have eight
episodes although I wish we were getting
more episodes we did find out some great
news about the shorten season one of
House of the Dragons directors said
there are eight wonderful episodes with
so much happening in every episode and
we had trouble at times making sure they
were only 1 hour long writer and
showrunner Ryan Condell made sure to
give it a good opening and a good ending
and each episode is jammed with
emotional and Visually exciting events
so while it is unfortunate we are
getting less episodes at least it does
sound like there won't be any filler
when you think about how House of the
Dragons first season ended I believe we
will be Off to the Races immed
immediately after the second season
begins every dragon and all hell is
about to break loose in Westeros this
season and I for one cannot wait now
let's have a look at what HBO said after
Matt Smith revealed that information
like I said earlier we have already
known House of the Dragon will release
this summer but thanks to Matt Smith
this was the first of us hearing about
it releasing in August when you think
about it that date does make sense
considering that's also when the first
season came out however what he said
wasn't an official announcement because
it kind of sounded like he was guessing
although he should have a good idea of
when it will happen but then HBO came
out and said we have nothing to announce
about a debut date or month for the
second season so as you can see HBO
neither confirmed or denied what he said
I don't know about all of you but I'm
going to go ahead and believe what he
said until I hear something else that's
official now we will find out the exact
date eventually when HBO finally does
release their first full trailer we
might even end up finding out before
that when they start releasing some more
official images for the new season I
guess it doesn't really matter when it
releases as long as it comes out this
summer I know I'm not alone when I say I
don't want to have to wait any longer
I'm more than ready to see the second
season and what Havoc House Targaryen
will bring in order to secure the Iron
Throne as always I will let you know
when and if I find out any more
information about House of the Dragon A
Song of Ice and Fire or any other Game
of Thrones show under development at HBO
it won't be long before more info Finds
Its way into my videos make sure you
subscribe that way you're the first to
know whenever that does happen also let
me know what you think about Matt's
interview down below do you believe what
he said or do you think it will release
on another date I'd love to hear what
you think once again I have to thank all
of you for watching another video I hope
all of you have a great day I will see
you again very soon
bye
[Music]